on serait très intéressant entre les
deux chasses bras et les pandas de chine
dont qui ont tous les deux perdu donc
voilà que vous pour une 3e place
on va dire anecdotique quand même un
masque voilà y'a pas grand chose en jeu
non plus je crois qu'il ya 4000 dollars
de différence
ce qui pour des joueurs de ce niveau là
voilà par rapport à toute la saison
c'est c'est vraiment rien du tout et
donc match match sans grande importance
eux mais quand même avec des beaux
joueurs alors à quel point les joueurs
seront impliqués dans le match je n'en
sais rien maintenant
bah écoutez on va sur ce match là et
c'est espérer un match intéressant
on verra on verra bien ce que ce que ça
donne les arméniens ont quand même grand
favori de la compétition qui ont qui ont
montré hier qu'ils étaient qu'ils
étaient forts et a comme prévu un je
vous avais dire moi je les place et
grand favori
on verra s'ils réussissent à
à réaliser le même exploit enfin la même
performance en finale ou si baisse un
peu de rythme possible qu'ils aient
qu'ils aient une petite baisse de régime
à un moment donné tati vont se dire
avant fou mais vraiment trop fort on
doit laisser une petite chance aux
autres on verra on verra on verra mais à
mon avis s'ils veulent vraiment la
gagner cette finale
s'il souhaite vraiment gagner cette
finale il là il la gagneront sans aucun
doute les les arméniens sent quand même
être en grande forme des joueurs
vraiment spécialiste un des joutes sur
internet qui montrent qu'ils vont tous
tous leur niveau lors lors de ces lors
de ces compétitions lors de ces joutes
donc sur sur le net et qui seront très
très dure à aller à les déboulonner
maintenant voilà tout tout est possible
exploit un exploit de l'équipe
américaine est aussi possible
un espoir de l'équipe américaine est
aussi possible mais bon il faudra il
faudra vraiment vraiment un grand match
de fabiano est ce les sauts dominguez et
jeffrey jiang pour battre ces arméniens
qui semble qui sans marcher sur l'eau
depuis quatre saisons déjà
qui sans marcher sur l'eau depuis quatre
saisons et qui sont vraiment des poids
lourds de cette compétition donc on
verra demain en tout cas ils ont éliminé
les deux chats devra inquiète lé
deuxième grand favori assez facilement a
finalement salué manuel échec
donc on va se suivre ce petit match on
voit comme je vous disais l'enjeu la
troisième place à mon avis non l'enjeu
est inexistant dans ce match soyons
soyons très sérieux mais
hun sen veut pas jouer banon écoute il a
il a décidé de ne pas jouer pour parler
de chasse brassac lecce devra à lille 0
2 chaises bras et 0 canadiens ce qui est
un peu ce qui est un peu étonnant ils
ont fait ils ont décidé de de faire une
équipe que j'appellerais une équipe de
mercenaires de payer à tour de bras des
grands maîtres de premier plan pour les
faire jouer
c'était une décision après
leur équipe est inférieure à celle de
l'arménie comme on l'a vu il faudra
peut-être
réfléchir dans l'est dans les années et
mois à venir a aligné une équipe
peut-être plus plus compétitive a
recruté à recruter les joueurs qu'il
faut
et peut-être que dès que des joueurs
comme commanderie ancian qui n'a plus
été titularisé avec avec l'équipe
d'arménie pourrait pourrait être un
choix un choix intéressant pour cette
équipe une recrue intéressante peut-être
pour remplacer guy riquiqui avait l'air
un peu guy et ariane paris qui n'ont pas
eu l'air dans leur assiette peut être
recruté voilà les joueurs que les que
les arméniens ont mis de côté andrian
cyan et et cauet et sarkissian qui ont
fait deux très grosses saisons qui n'ont
pas été sélectionnés pour cette finale
peut-être des problèmes en interne
mais à mais qui pourraient être des
recrues intéressantes pour les deux
chaises bras pour pour la saison
prochaine
à voir elle salua élevé qu'à tout cas
ces arméniens qui faisait office
d'épouvantail dès le début de la saison
en venant à parler je me rappelle on
avait fait un petit point avec fabien
avant la compétition parler des favoris
on avait mis les arméniens comme grand
grand favori de la compétition ne
s'était pas trompé on avait mis saint
louis à bishop's et l'arménie comme les
deux très grands favoris de la
compétition s'était pas on ne s'était
pas trompés ils se retrouveront en
finale
nietzsche bras qui semblait un peu moins
fort et à et les chinois qui auraient pu
aussi les chinois les chinois et les
canadiens qui étaient peut-être au
niveau des dessins louis est ce que
j'avais contre un des joueurs chinois
établissait conquis chao et qui est
assez impressionnant sur internet qui
était assez impressionnant
enfin ils ont ils ont ils n'ont pas pas
pas réussi à créer a créé a créé la
surprise à part il ya déjà des
propositions deux nuls à voilà une nulle
qui est déjà signé entre li chao et gris
tchouk c'est sûr comme je vous disais
l'implication des joueurs va être minime
1 aujourd'hui match pour la troisième
place quasiment quasiment aucun enjeu
même plus que quasiment même totalement
hmm hmm hmm côté de chasse bras on et
ils ont commencé le live un peu en
avance on a trois cents 300 spectateurs
allez les supporters les supporters des
bras ne sont pas présents ils ont décidé
de déserter les tribunes quelques
d'orange voix il ya 4000 dollars en jeu
pour toute l'équipe ce qui par rapport
au coût faramineux que peuvent avoir ces
équipes là c'est vraiment une
une une pièce a entre guillemets et du
gros écart sur les demi-finales à hvar
son bail out well et saint loup gris
shop ont quand même bien dominé les
chinois ils ont vraiment dominé le match
de a à z et les arméniens qui était gros
favoris contre lecce ce bras on
l'emporté alors y ait eu un peu de
suspens à la fin de la deuxième ronde on
a pu penser à ce que ce que les bras et
est devant mais bon les arméniens ont
décidé d'accélérer
ils ont accéléré ils ont ils ont fait la
différence et ils ont fait la différence
voilà on a la petite à la petite petrov
marianne paris contre 10000 irène on
peut suivre anish giri on va dire que
les deux équipes les plus forts courants
porter quoi les deux équipes les plus
forts que l'on emporte est d'avoir
aujourd'hui un c'est comme je vous
disais n'ya pas y'a pas mon avis
l'implication des joueurs va pas être
total ya déjà une nulle entre entre grid
choukhevitch alors je vous ai mis les
cran en dessous l'écran des scores
individuels en fait aujourd'hui pour
changer un peu pâle et haddock mais les
scores individuels dont classe et chic
et numéro 1 contre leucate est-ce que tu
participeras la prochaine saison
bah ouais alors après il n'est pas
annoncé donc ya pas on n'a pas encore
les règles de la prochaine saison
donc on verra après faut aussi que faut
aussi que que les joueurs aient envie de
jouer
je te cache pas que l'épouvantail
arménien peu un petit peu démotivé les
troupes un parce que c'est vrai que face
à face à une équipe aussi forte
il paraît difficile de pouvoir rivaliser
donc c'est vrai que les hommes sont pas
forcément on verra si la motivation
qu'on peut avoir mais mais c'est vrai
que face à face à face à des équipes si
forte c'est vrai que tu tu sais que ça
va être difficile quand même d'aller
d'aller jusqu'au bout donc on verra on
verra ce qu'on ce qu'on fait mais c'est
vrai que ça peut ça quand tu as quand
même des armadas pareil on fasse c'est
compliqué on va quand même les de chasse
aux rats qui ont mis les moyens cette
saison se sont cassé les dents et
j'aurais mis les moyens avec great loong
irissarry chat arrive donc à une grosse
équipe ils auraient pu mettre aussi
fille ruth jacky n'a pas pu jouer
alors est ce qu'il n'a pas pu jouer
parce qu'il a il va jouer le norwich s
il est en quarantaine je sais pas
exactement j'en connais pas les raisons
enfin tout du moins
compliqué donc il ya un échange des
dames checker que tout soit bien
benjamin donc je sais pas écoute on
verra pour la finale le favori bat
normalement l'équipe d'arménie
quand même qu'ils qui était déjà
favorite là il me semble quand même
favori pour l'affinage des migrants
favori contre les barrages mais je m'y
étais pas trompé après ils sont pas à
l'abri d'une baisse de régime un tout
d'un coup on sait jamais que voilà
petite baisse de régime ça peut arriver
et du coup les américains pourraient
laférois et fuite au lieu de rock
surimposer cavaliers cet échec
c'est ce que le roi avait repris la
ferme 8 bref 8 bon rock était le coup
numéro alors dit donc ouais pour pour
moi pour moi l'arménie sera favorite
après frais voilà on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'une baisse de régime
on verra on verra comment ça se passe
bon là c'est oui avec les blancs ça peut
se retourner ce position de garenne
ariane paris c'est un peu chaud
positions complexes et là il ya
peut-être fou prend fc3 preuve cette
dame c'est quatre dames français 5
manger leur dit qu'ils m'aident à le
voir mais honnêtement c'est un truc que
j'aurais vu en 3 + 2 donc peut-être que
dingli rennes se prend cette tactique
après je vous dis un pouce et c'est
difficile de rester motivé pour pour un
match pour la troisième place c'est pas
évident à gérer quand il n'y a pas
d'enjeu du tout c'est les échecs surtout
en cadence plus longue c'est un jeu qui
est très difficile à jouer quand il ya
zéro en jeu parce que je n'en avais déjà
parlé dans d'autres stream et les échecs
c'est quand même pour moi un art martial
un sport de combat et comme dans tout
sport de combat en fait il faut il faut
mettre des ingrédients pour pour bien
jouer et qu'encore n'y a pas de
motivation quand il n'ya pas de carotte
du tout il ya vraiment 0-0 en jeu ça
peut être
ça peut être compliqué alors c'est
différent quand tu vas dans la d'heures
que tu oublies 203 +0 tutea si tu as
envie de jouer tu te donnes un plafond
quoi mais mais quand on me force à jouer
un match qui sert à rien en fait c'est
très difficile de se mettre en forme un
club pour pourrait corroborer mes propos
bon là dingli rennes qui file un pion
comme ça sur à une double attaque en
deux coups c'est quand même rare et la
partie de grisou contre li chao ils ont
fait nul aussi vite que possible
donc ils ont clairement pas envie de
jouer quoi donc 6 voilà c'est ça a été
vu par yara rien de paris bien
évidemment mais mais oui les joueurs qui
quand on met pas les ingrédients on rate
on se prend des tactiques on rate des
trucks et c'est tout à fait normal et je
ne jetterai pas la pierre aux joueurs je
ne jetterai pas la pierre aux joueurs
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
normal
après ça c'était plus tard à ton boulot
sans forcément de raisons tu vas pas
spécialement beau c'est quoi ça te papa
pata pata pas envie quoi c'est tout à
fait normal c'est tout à fait normal
c'est humain et donc on va pas on va pas
en vouloir aux joueurs de devoir de
montrer un niveau de jeu moindre mal en
tout cas c'est une grosse tactique
en plus il est déconnecté ding ouais
c'est sûr il doit pas avoir la tête à
jouer
ouais les chinois en plus il est ici il
est peut-être un peu tard chez zoé
doivent pas suivre ils doivent pas avoir
vraiment la motive c'est normal on ne
leur en voudra pas et ça lui a amené
rodin on n'en voudra pas aux joueurs
on va rester un peu sur la partie de
tahri on va voir comment didier reynès
et l'egypte étaient juste des
connecteurs disons que dans les partis
officiels et encore la carotte de lait
l'eau et les candidats sont censés
remplir le 1er novembre avec un terrain
bourg exactement alex versons mais je
suis un peu inquiet parce que comme
comme je suis russophile et russophone
je suis un peu les news en russie l
épidémie de coronavirus reprend aussi en
russie
et quand même le 1er novembre c'est loin
donc ils ont ils ont en général genre
deux trois semaines de décalage par
rapport à l'europe sur sur leur épidémie
entre deux semaines et un mois
blatt et ils vont avoir trois semaines
un mois de décalage mais donc ça veut
dire qu'il pourrait dans la situation
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui en france on
va dire vers le 20 novembre
donc ça ça peut ça peut ça peut être
compliqué alors il ya des plans b mais
mais bon faut aussi que je suis quand
même un peu inquiets pas face à la
reprise de l'épidémie qui est présente
ça peut
on peut on peut se retrouver dans
exactement la même situation qu'en mars
alors que la digue irène est juste en
train de perdre sur sur des connexions
elle a été déconnecté très longtemps à
mon avis ça il a retrouvé sa connexion
il a retrouvé sa connexion
heureusement pour lui sinon on était mal
sinon on était même très mal ma chance
la dame va revenir en c4 il va taper le
pion des quatre il va gagner la partie
tranquille
c'est terrible c'est terrible
difficile un pur pour le joueur chinois
dans les autres partis se passe quoi
geek est gagnant voit gagnant donc et
pas gagné en vérité une position
agréable avec les noirs contre contre
eux oui je m'emballe ça c'est un peu
mieux pour les noirs ce qu'ils ont un
peu d' attaque sur le roi de sa reach
bon on va avoir avec les chinois sur le
papier sont quand même plus fort on va
voir comment ça se passe ici
on va voir comment ça se passe ici
terrible c'est terrible alors la foux
trois noms parce que la dame est attaqué
si c'est de cette position que tu parles
lvk
si tu parles cette position dame c4 et
le coup logique un turc ou la tour et tu
maintiens le clouage ici j'ai pas
exactement ce qu'ils calculent mais doit
calculer des trucs et salue ce frenchy
frog il fait dame ces cas d'accord il
cloud
pourquoi pas ça va les prendre à jouer
des français 3 il va récupérer le pion
des cadreurs seeding la sauver après son
calme favoris sur le papier les chinois
mais bon ils ont les problèmes de
connexion ils ont pas l'air d'être très
concerné est salutaire de kmc reprendre
des quatre il peut prendre du plomb ou
de la tour 7 tours prend d'ailleurs
façon il n'ya pas d'échec
la tour est cloué la prix du pion sur
des saints qui a peut-être tour un échec
donc fouet f4 d'abord qui va mettre la
dame en b3 et c'est qu'un pion de plus
c'est pas encore gagné et ça lui joue
l'un
x 8
parfois c'est peut-être de faire des
cinq des six 17 mar les autres partis
oui guérissent étendu sa part contre
juillan guy paré par malin il va
peut-être réussir à mettre un pion à a3
et à réseauter les blancs alors d'être
plutôt sympa donc yoyogi devrait gagner
avec les noirs tahri devrait gagner avec
les blancs et ça se jouera sur guiry du
coup ça lui le gouverneur salut salut
on va voir ce que font la d66 ve 17 le
four en voyant 17 y en est une tour en
vain il fait à manger trois diamètres la
tour en vain salut berly sandales ce
palais sans valve qui étaient là hier
soir pour les blitz ça on a pas mal vite
c'est hier c'était cool hier c'était
sympa à l'accession de blitz sa prison
en prison
il veut faire tour 17 hier c'était cool
hein
c'était plus cool de la que la prod
plastique du coup c'est plus coûteux
l'approach hesling même bac et a pris
des notes ouais y avait d'un match 4 des
recettes qui était peut-être intéressant
mesdames c3 pour dams et 7 c cool aussi
un tu as fini quand du coup on a fini
vers 1h du mat je crois en quelque chose
comme ça c'était cool je pensais que
j'aurais épuisé finalement c'était pas
si mal poussé si ce truc ça paralyse le
fou g3 il y aura ma tanger 2
sue arrière merci ludo pour le design 3
alors comme on finit le taf peut-être
dame prend 1,7 pour dames b8 ça devrait
gagner ça non pour ces sept pour dams
est ce efficace aussi il va échanger
il va faire tourner ses 8 et 17 des huit
allées c'est perdu pour ding est-ce que
geri va pouvoir la gagner son fouet plus
actifs
ouais bah qui a kiffé ya main puisque je
voulais vraiment pas mal il ya un
olivier olivier moi je jouais vraiment
pas mal hier
je m'en suis quand même je faisais je
faisais des games et game sympa
mécanisme les coups de pied après le
match d'hier je sais pas mais il avait
l'air un peu désabusé mais après ils
sont tombés contre les grands favoris de
la compétition leur lien donc bon pour
moi comme quand l'équipe du carroi je
compte les arméniens je vois là je me
suis dit de façon nous quand on a perdu
contre l'équipe d'hikaru on aurait joué
contre l'arménie ans en quart de finale
nos chances étaient maigres 1 face à
sénart ma d'appareils et du coup bas les
chaises brasse s'en sont peut-être
arriver ils pensaient peut-être être
favori mais c'était loin d'être le cas
quoi peut-être qu'ils ont eu l'illusion
d'être plus fort mais
et y'a pas un monde où il était favori
de ce match vient de signer avec 27 60
malheureusement malheureusement il ya un
un castor des neiges qui m'a un peu pris
des points à la fin deux castors des
neiges même j'ai fini contre deux
castors des neiges dur de mon ter à 2008
quand tu te prends quand tu te rend
moins 25 moins 30 points à chaque fois
donc guy qui gagne aussi ça fait deux
ans et demi mais ça reach qui va perdre
ses affaires de et demi heure et demie
salah les perdantes un mini-match de
fait il n'en reste plus que trois ouais
le truc c'est que ça demande tellement
d'efforts en plus de gagner une partie
que quand tu perds contre un castor des
neiges derrière franchement ça fait mal
psychologiquement
la ja roi prend 1,5 et très fort mais
bon il va y avoir abandon tour prend 17
il ya un coût de tours suivi de g1 et
donc on va regarder les scores
individuels c'est pas mal ça reach qui a
perdu contre yun junghee c'est vraiment
un heavy rain qui aura coûté à son
équipe
sedin xvi rennes qui aura coûté cher à
son équipe
alors qu'on arrive petit à petit en 63
mais bon on est très peu nombreux après
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on est quand
même plus que dans les autres langues
donc ça veut dire que on n'est également
pas intéressés par la compétition que
dans les autres pays espagne sont 140 en
russie sont 90 en allemand ils sont neuf
ans portugais 10 alors que normalement
ils sont pas ils sont pas si loin
chase son 3000e risque est très très peu
en étant première page de chess comme et
en mettant le truc
honnêtement tu mets un écran noir était
déjà 2500 je crois en gros avec le
nombre de faux lors qu'ils ont et ses
terrasses et je pense qu un écran noir
temps entre 2005 et 3005 tout le temps
donc ça intéresse vraiment personne
c'est terrible c'est terrible le plus
grand est quand même les chaises bras
qu'avec leurs teams sont prêts à 270
quoi
c'est fou j'imagine si on faisait une
team bleed stream est con
en fassions de compet ou quoi on n'est
jamais - 2000 quand on fait des trucs
qu'on fasse des matches entre nous qu'on
fasse quoi qu'on fasse on est on est
toujours on est toujours plus que ce à
quoi on fait montre à quel point suivant
l'exemple et y ait des joueurs qui
coûtent une fortune et tous c'est pour
montrer à quel point comme les gens sont
pas attachés à cette compét qui aura une
belle première saison finalement et puis
au fil des saisons le l'intérêt à
l'intérêt abc petit à petit et là c'est
vrai qu'on est un peu là l'apogée du nom
d'intérêts pour cette compét
après peut-être que peut-être qu'il ya
des équipes voilà qui sont qui sont qui
sont trop forte a quand même une armada
comme je le disais un terrain quand même
une armada arménienne qui décourage un
peu les autres hein c'est difficile
quand add des clubs comme ça qu'ils sont
vraiment beaucoup plus fort que les
autres
après peut-être peut-être aux autres
clubs et même à nous de réfléchir à
recruter peut-être andrien sûr comme je
le disais en début de retransmission qui
semble un peu être mis sur la touche et
sarksian ces deux joueurs qui sont un
peu m me sous la touche
côté arménien qui serait peut-être de
d'excellentes recrues 1 une équipe super
force d'être ils sont très durs à
détrôner les arméniens ils ont vraiment
l'air très très forts sont vraiment très
très fort franchement pour les détrôner
peut-être en finale ils pourront
peut-être sous la pression il jouera un
peu moins bien qui c'est c'est toujours
c'est toujours possible mais à mais mais
mais mais ils sont ils seront ils seront
très très dure à prendre
ils seront très très dure à prendre
je crois que les arméniens sur internet
et n'ont perdu qu'un match en quatre
saisons quand même et je suis même pas
sûr mais je crois qu'ils ont perdu qu'un
match sur sur 40 rencontres cccd c'est
des joueurs très forts
tu prends de prison une section sur la
touche en or qui est énorme n'en ai
aucune idée on les avait deux joueurs
vraiment il y en énorme adrian sion et
sarksian qui qui était dominant aussi
dans les title tuesday qui étaient
dominants de partout qui sont un peut du
jour au lendemain
arrêtez de jouer sur internet pourquoi
ils sont donc avoir un énorme niveau
c'est pas vraiment mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que ça pourrait être deux
très grosses recrues il ya qui dans
l'équipe arménienne n'y a par am il ya
tigran petrossian il y ait martirossian
et il le tire onac ça doit ni on veut on
peut voir on peut voir demain mais donc
il était voilà ça là on a les équipes
d'aujourd'hui
donc c'était l'équipe les bras qui
mettait la même équipe mais l'équipe
d'arménie qui sera demain en finale
voilà je vais je voulais mettre pour
qu'on les voit bien mais ouais non ils
sont alors on va on va bien aller voir
tu avec mama mama gas mc do maqsoud au
premier martirossian de tetro sion aux
trois héros naksa doit ni aux quatre
mois c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
très très grosse équipe demain il faudra
il faudra vraiment un grand un grand
caruana un grand dominguez un grand saut
et un grand lyon que pour pour pour
réussir à mettre à mal cette équipe
arménienne
malgré tout mais pour moi ils sont quand
même favori de la finale quoi qu'il en
soit par adrian sion ouais mais sarksian
et comme une perf à 28,50 un feed
donc non à mon avis on a il faudra une
grosse perf des américains pour battre
cette équipe
on verra on verra si les américains en
sont capables en tout cas en tout cas
les canadiens n'ont pas réussi à
réaliser l'exploit
on verra on verra si les américains eux
en sont capables avec un meilleur sur le
papier non non je ne crois pas je crois
que je crois pas qu ils off on verra
demain déjà déjà hier on m'avait fait la
même réflexion etc en me disant les bras
les bras les canadiens plus fort nanani
nanana on a vu le résultat
on m'avait dit la même chose quand il a
joué contre l'équipe d'icare où ils les
ont ils les ont terrassé jeu
c'est l'effet du jouet sur un biker
enterrement superbe et très fort sur
internet non sur internet ntn élevé il
sourit sont ils sont ils sont ils sont
très très bons sont très très bon
présage
il avait juste un peu plus de mal en
présentiel l'année dernière sur les demi
finales mais bon c'est serment des
spécialistes du jeu sur internet ils
sont ils sont vraiment très bons ainsi
rien du tout pas mal non non tu y vas y
vas y va se prendre attention attention
on parle pas comme ça des armes et un
second à un ban temporaire pas mme
soleil ayasse tension un tension ils
seront en bane temporaire de de dix
minutes 1 c de la surinterprétation
c'est n'importe quoi
ils sont très forts moi je regarde les
résultats je vois 40 matchs je crois
qu'ils sont 39 victoires ils ont des
perfs à 28,50 ils sont très très fort
c'est tout tous ils sont très très fort
c'est le bal le pann le bas de dix
minutes est parti attention heureusement
heureusement robin side et là ils
veillent au grain par le pas comme
notre équipe favorite et oui et oui il
faut veiller tension c'est le fait de
jouer sur internet gym et gym et est ce
qui fait qu il fait vraiment la
différence et c'est le fait de jouer sur
le net c'est le fait de jouer sur le net
puisque après quand tu joues en rapide
en sueur et chic et 3d ils ont du mal
c'est vraiment le jeu sur internet là
ils sont c'est là vraiment c'est leur
spécialité sont redoutables
on est sévère mais bon c'est d'un autre
côté c'est pas un badge afin que j'ai
mis j'ai mis un 10 minutes j'ai mis un
10 minutes mais ils font beaucoup de
buzz à lörrach beaucoup de tactique
beaucoup de blitz ils sont très forts
très forts et très régulier on verra
demain si si caruana saut et compagnie
peuvent faire quelque chose mais ça
s'annonce difficile
ça s'annonce compliqué ça s'annonce
compliqué mais bon et on est encore leur
équipe et affaiblir ils ont remis leur
manque
il leur manque deux de leurs deux de
leurs meilleurs joueurs quoi parce qu'à
mon avis un sarksian forme est plus fort
qu'un ça doit ni quand même donc ouais
en plus en plus en plus ils sont
affaiblis là pour les pour les pour les
phases finales
donc même même affaibli sont ils sont
redoutables donc imaginé avec l'équipe à
non je pense pour la saison prochaine
faut qu'on recrute des arméniens quoi
mais même artaq je me rappelle la saison
où il avait joué la première saison
artaq qui y voit là un joueur à 2100
2150 fidh
il avait fait une perf roy 25 91 26 50
ans est spécialiste aussi spécialiste
aussi carrément de grosses différences
et les autres jouets sur les échiquiers
jouant en ligne
pour certains oui papa pour tout le
monde mais à certains joueurs qui
vraiment qui vraiment
son décuple leur force continue sur
internet
pl qui décuple leur force et qui eux qui
jouent beaucoup mieux
bon alors cette prochaine honda est ce
qu'elle va commencer avec les bras
non ne pas avoir de la terre ça en face
je sais pas il ya un truc un truc qui se
passe une alchimie ya une alchimie
bon allez c'est reparti as que great
food va nous refaire une nulle hyper
rapide dont il a le secret ou est ce
qu'avec les blancs il va essayer quelque
chose
connaissant le loustic les matches comme
ça il s'en fiche totale après il va
peut-être sentir obligé de jouer parce
qu'il doit avoir une bonne rémunération
pour le match mais avec les noirs c'est
sûr qu'il peut faire deux nuls rapide y
fera avec les blancs je pense qu'il va
se sentir obligé d'essayer de gagner
quand même par principe
c'est le gars tu te sens meilleur sur la
tête non moi je t'ai pas et quand
j'étais très entraînés sur l'échiquier
gt gt aussi bon comme j'ai expliqué hier
j'ai raconté des anecdotes je fais des
matches contre j'ai fait un match qu'on
tient qu'aux venco où j'avais perdu 3-2
et on avait fait un tie break à 2-2 donc
il était quand même 27 25 où on a joué
tu as 25 27 25 fit alors après il se
faisait pas attention contre moi ils
jouent un peu tranquille mais après deux
parties quand il a dû accélérer on a
refait rhin et là la cinquième partie
tie break
il m'a flag et parce que la pollution
était égal quoi donc non gt gt très bon
très bon sur l'échiquier sais c'est rare
quand même les gens qui jouent vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup mieux sur sur ordi
mais ça arrive ça arrive je peux vous
pouvez demander à robin ça est justement
qui est dans le pied dans le tchat
il va vous confirmez quoi s'il est
encore tout à certains joueurs qui ont
vraiment tout à fait vrai cc c'est rare
il en a pas énormément mais voilà il ya
une petite proportion de gens qui voient
là sont vraiment bien bien meilleur et
ça on peut pas
à peux pas l'expliquer quoi on sait pas
ce qu'ils sont plus détendus est ce que
c'est la vision 2d qui fait vraiment la
10ème mois que
suis meilleur sur internet parce que je
joue beaucoup sur internet par contre
laissé plus à cause ou parce que enfin
ça à cause du fait que je joue ou
exclusivement sur internet mais à si je
jouais autant que je joue sur
l'échiquier normal il n'y aurait pas de
différence
enfin j'étais bon blitzer quoi du coup
et donc je le suis à je suis sur
internet aussi mais à mai après voilà
c'est plus une question d'entraînement
mais le niveau est sensiblement le même
question d'habitude il ya quelques
petits réglages à faire entre internet
et à un échiquier normale notamment sur
le flag events live chat noir croate way
exact reste étonnant qu'ils aient pas
mis en scène suis assez d'accord avec
vous je suis assez étonné qu'ils aient
par en scène qui joue je suis assez
étonné
tarifs 5/3 dre ça j'ai répondu alors
cette partie on sait pas dingli rennes
il a ignoré d'être en freestyle total en
fait
attendez je vais juste répond téléphone
sans appel 10 mille fois on sait jamais
qui soit quelque chose d'important
désolé c'était ces terrains important
mais comme ça plaît
je suis on sait jamais que ce soit grave
c'est rare en travers dans l'ombre tu
penses que tu aurais pu atteindre
combien de l'or c'est toujours une
question difficile peut être le problème
déjà c'est que
en fait la question elle seule elle se
coupe aussi aussi vite aussi directement
du fait que j'avais pas envie de le
faire parce que je considérais - enfin
moi ce que je considérais c'est que
pouvait faire 2005 2005 50 au max et
donc considérant que c'était le mieux
que je puisse faire entrailles ardents
j'ai pensé que ça serve à rien de le
faire donc je n'ai pas fait donc tu vas
sur une question qui est pas simple en
tout cas moi c'est ce que je considérais
à l'époque et considérant ça en fait je
n'ai pas envie de faire du try hard donc
c'est faux faut prendre aussi toutes les
toutes les choses dont considération tu
vois le fait de pas pouvoir faire au
moins 2000 6,50 2007 a fait que j'avais
pas envie de le faire ce qui fait que
j'aurais jamais fait try hard donc c'est
très difficile à dire
c'est très difficile à dire
en tout cas ce que je peux dire c'est
que je pensais que je ne ferais pas
mieux de 25 50 et donc peut-être quelque
chose entre eux 24 50 et 25 53 m'a gardé
le sont parce que j'ai coupé le son mais
pas mais pas la sonnerie s'arrête fuites
de carbone à être une hanche avait déjà
décidé d arrêter avant bien heureusement
pas par d'être très bien niggli rennes
en rien il ya l'ambition pense à ton
martial et combien 25 25 50
par contre ça c'est sûr que je vais
aller à peu près ça parce que j'ai fait
masse de match d'entraînement contre
vlad à l'époque juste un peu le sparring
quand j'avais 18 ans donc j'ai fait
masse de match avec flight je fais des
matches avec mur tu as joué comme je le
dis un petit match conte iakovenko jouer
des matchs contre inard kiev
j'ai joué contre plein de matchs contre
des gens qui étaient entre 26 et 27 50
et je me faisais jamais je me faisais
jamais lavés en fait et il n'aurait pas
voulu faire de match de ce parking de
sparring partner avec moi si je jouais
pas au moins à 25,24 50,25 des meilleurs
actuellement non ah non pas du tout
pleutres en fait tu imagines pas que en
fait j'ai une baisse de niveau entre 10
enfin entre 20 ans et 27 ans quand j'ai
26 ans où j'ai arrêté de jouer en fait
entre 19 et 25 26 ou et quand j'ai
arrêté
donc là j'ai grandement baissé niveau et
puis je les récupérer après mai
mais à l'époque sur icc dans la d'heure
cinq minutes j'ai quand même réussi à
faire top 5 me trompe top-10 monde
défaire top-10 monde dans la d'heure ils
cesser de l'époque dans le ladder cinq
minutes hissé de l'époque ait moins de
monde qui jouait sur internet
qu'aujourd'hui mais
qui faire table 10 monde quand même
c'était pas facile sur ce ladder là
après j'ai pas réussi à le conserver
mais je réussissais à tourner aux
alentours de la 50e 60e place
donc c'était pas mal ont une minute
j'avais fait aussi top-10 monde dans le
ladder et là y avait du monde qui jouait
en faisant du try hard sur internet et
comme je vous disais quand je jouais
quand jouer c'est simple quand je jouais
sur icc j'avais j'avais j'avais réussi à
monter à 3020 à l'époque est le numéro
un mondial un moment donné c'était vlad
et vlad il était 3320 donc j'étais à 300
points du numéro un mondial
donc ce serait l'équivalent de 2900 de
1950 sur czech comme aujourd'hui où
hockey entre 28 50 et 29,50 je dirais ok
peut-être ses 29 50 mais comme il ya
plus de monde qui joue on va dire que
c'est 28 50
donc ouais je tournais aux alentours de
ouais c'est comme si je tourne et
aujourd'hui au lieu d'être entre 2007 et
2008 on va dire j'étais entre 2008 25 et
2009 25 ans fait en gros bonjour à
conques
non pas du tout le match mais comme vous
poser des questions c'est peut-être plus
plus intéressant au final mais ouais je
dirais que jouer peut-être way 75 500
points de mieux qu'aujourd'hui jusqu'à
au mieux et j'avais des ouvertures aussi
à l'époque en fait est que je jouais pas
vraiment mieux
peut-être que du coup je compense le
calcul par les connaissances en finale
etc
je suis bien mieux qu'avant mais à
l'époque la différence surtout que
j'étais bien préparé dans les ouvertures
sortait bien des ouvertures en fait pas
tout le temps mais je sortais
correctement des ouvertures de partout
et il s'essaie c'était un truc
s'appelait internet chaque club
c'était l'endroit où tout le monde joue
en fait à l'époque
c'est difficile de comparer loach est
comme aller lougheed tu jouais sur place
chez ce nom jouer jouer jouer sur i say
say mais achetez achetez j'étais
vraiment bien ouais ça existe encore
burly sandales sauf que c'est sauf que
c'est vide mais oui non gt gt gt
vraiment pas malin comme lui je me
rappelle que ces blagues qui était
numéro un est dans un moment il ya eu
great choquer tout ça et j'étais genre
300 points derrière ce qui est beaucoup
et peu à la fois en fait ce qui était
beaucoup et peu à la fois
question peut-être un i7 ça ne souhaite
pas que ta femme osef des échecs au
contraire au contraire pleutres ce
serait plus un problème pour moi si ma
femme était à fond sur les échecs parce
que du coup je suis à tout le temps à
fond sur les échecs et c'est plutôt une
chance en fait à 30 mètres à 3 100
points de vue là à l'époque c'était
vraiment bien ce qu'à l'époque c'était
vraiment un groupe leader quoi qu on
fait cornetto va y pense plus échec que
moi en fait ça me sens que ça se
retourne un peu là la position mais bon
je sais pas se passe quoi sur les autres
guiry qui a déjà fait nul est non mais
c'est clair que la cd que ça peut faire
nul vite ça fait nul vite aujourd'hui
car est peut-être une position d'
attaque pour lyon guy en est où ici la
vie chère qui se couchait qui dort échec
une grille car une bonne position quand
même là le fouet cette qui a un peu
moche et le fou qui va venir en f3 qui
défendra g2 qui attaquera bessette
reviennent dans le match
enfin il va être trop fort aux échecs en
nette hausse et pas sûr qu'ils aiment
les et chacun son gamin et la femme à
baky et ouais la femme de baqi al jouer
aux échecs
enfin ils jouent toujours aux échecs
mais elle fait elle ne fait pas de
carrière donc elle confie je suis pas
sûr je passais les dents le chat elle
pourra nous répondre je suis pas sûr que
ça intéresse à l essai c'est une bonne
joueuse un mais
c'est même une très bonne joueuse mais
qu'elle ait pas à fond sur les échecs
si c'était la question est ce que j'ai
joué en blind
voilà je suis pas du tout entraîné donc
j'aurai du mal mais mais quand j'étais
entraîneur oui c'est pas très dur en
vrai c'est une question d'entraînement
version itunes ma soirée avec meilleur
parti de ddr league wayne est
complètement maintenant comme illégal il
ya moi ma femme elle ne joue pas du tout
aux échecs en fait ça ne m'intéresse pas
elle comprend ce matin par contre on a
un peu discuté échec pour la peine elle
comprenait pas comment y avait tout le
temps des compétitions elle m'a dit
comment c'est possible en fait j'ai
l'impression que toutes les semaines
vous avez des compétitions qui commence
et c'est qu'ils regardent en fait elle
comprenait pas comment c'était possible
que que tous les jours il ya une
nouvelle compétition quoi elle me dit
mais c'est assez incroyable en fait
c'est s'arrête jamais g us et c'est un
concept les échecs casque et d'un run le
plus aux échecs qui m'impressionne le
plus long c'est là le lab la puissance
de calcul de mecs comme maxime en fait
ça m'impressionne parce que moi même
j'étais censé plutôt bien calculer donc
c'est un domaine où je suis plutôt bon
de base
enfin je suis censé être bon et en fait
par rapport à ces mecs là je suis
inexistant en fait et donc ça
m'impressionne dans le sens c'est
quelque chose où j'ai des facilités
naturel donc je me dis bon ok j'ai des
facilités et je le fais plutôt bien et
de me rends compte que par rapport à des
gars comme maxime en fait je suis juste
nul en fait complètement nul et ça
m'impressionne qui est des gens qui me
ridiculise dans un domaine où suisse est
déjà censé être bon et qui me plaît en
fait donc tu vas j'aimais bien calculer
et j'aime bien calculer c'est un truc
qui me qui m'a beaucoup amusé aux échecs
et donc j'ai essayé on va dire
naturellement de progresser dans ce
domaine là c'est un truc que j'aimais
bien travaillé en plus mais mais du coup
ça m'impressionne qui est des mecs qui
me ridiculise en fait là dedans
différence de calcul à cannes nouvelle
c'est la profondeur des coûts le nombre
de positions le fait qu'il voit des
couples subtil fuite s'est tous réunis
sandales ce c'est juste tout en fait
parce que j'arrive à ne pas penser échec
dans la vie de tous les jours ouais très
simplement fait fait souvent quand
j'étais à mon ordinateur et que j'arrête
de bosser en fait j'ai passé tellement
d'heures en fait à faire des échecs
en fait mon cerveau idée manche
complètement en revanche ne pas penser
au stream et tout ça c'est plus
difficile
en fait je dirais quasiment que ma
passion c'est plus de stream et que les
échecs en soit enfin j'adore jouer aux
échecs
mais ce serait difficile de dissocier
les deux en fait c'est ce que je faisais
c'était purement et simplement que des
échecs ça me lasserai on va dire que
j'adore j'adore stream et aussi donc
c'est plus le mélange des deux ça
à dire aussi un jour et je pensais que
mon point fort c'est la tactique et un
jour jouer contre maxime ça ça m'a fait
un peu le même effet vrai quand maxime
maxime te ridiculises quoi en tactique
je veux dire c'est vraiment un tacticien
hors pair
guy un point et demi voilà une victoire
une huile du coup pour geri en parlant
de grisou qu'il est peut-être bien
contre wailly et sa riche ding
s'échauffent on va rester sur cette
partie là
ouais mais c'est sûr que maximy les
files et il est tout simplement
impressionnant c'est fin c'est vraiment
incroyable
c'est même difficile si on joue pas très
bien aux échecs de se rendre compte à
quel point il est incroyable en fait il
est encore plus incroyable que ce que
vous pensez en fait ce que je veux dire
comment elle fait pour centrer nos
tactiques du quasi personne n'est
capable de le suivre dans ce domaine là
bas il résout des problèmes en fait
c'est le coach qui lui trouve des
problèmes et des exercices difficiles et
il est résout
mais c'est difficile de réaliser
tu sais comment apparemment je kiffe le
tennis et je vois bien que federer djoko
et nadal ils sont beaucoup plus forts
que les autres mais je pense que l'on
peut paraît enfin en tout cas moi je
peux pas réaliser à quel point il est
plus fort qu'un gars comme
comme steam ou quoi vous irez fou quoi
qui sont déjà complètement ouf
en fait je pense que c'est difficile de
réaliser le gouffre mais il doit être
énorme en réalité alors niveau est très
proche mais là elles adorent leur niveau
est très proche quand tu joues en 1 v1
mais le gouffre pour passer du niveau de
team à celui de federer ou 2 août nadal
pas ce qui se ressent peut-être un peu
plus le gouffre doit être juste
gigantesque well as le clip le clip on
n'a que que que ludique amis dans le
dans le best of du moi ou avec ba qui
ont dit oui mon gars ça de façon c'est
trop dur il va pas trouver maxime le
voit tempo c'est impressionnant
c'est vraiment vraiment les gars c'est
c'est juste incroyable
le gouffre est tellement énorme que je
pourrais me dire que je travaillerai
toute ma vie j'aurai jamais son niveau
en fait tellement tellement il est
incroyable c'est ça qu'il faut c'est ça
qu'il faut imaginer
cc c'est tout bonnement incroyable et il
est français
robbins haimoudi j'avais joué nv le
journal france jeunes ont moins de 14
ans lui n'en est que 11 et alan ellis
j'ai juste eu l'impression de pas jouer
au même jeu ou pas parler la même langue
que j'étais dans les dix meilleurs
français de mon âge mais bon moi j'ai eu
la même expérience mais c'est
hallucinant sa vitesse des beats
variante surtout qu'il était haut comme
trois pommes bah ouais j'ai eu la même
expérience que toi
sauf qu'à l'époque il avait encore un
talon d'achille maintenant il en a plus
vraiment
ce que j'ai vu que jamie goldman et en
stream qui te coûtera en 15 pluie soit
c'est probable contrant madoff by les
îles et 2009 160 en 2009 150 ans
blessure tenace comme donc envie de saw
6 1
c'est sûr qu'il est plus fort que moi de
1960 c'est un gros classement 1 2960 je
rivalise pas quoi c'est quoi ta on agit
de maxime le talon d'achille de maxime
c'est les positions fermes et il est
jouais pas très bien quand il quand on
pouvait pas trop calculer tout ça ils
n'étaient pas il n'était pas
irréprochable c'est pas mal là ce qu'il
a fait paris
et salue w est cependant pas d'à
donc bref si c'est alors quoi g4 g5 ou
et cette fois ça il faut calculer la
tour e 8 e ff7 d'arica et des six aussi
indécise ça fait mal
en quoi maxime pas par rapport à
karlsson peut-être que carlos est il un
meilleur placement de pièces naturel
qu'elle est pas juste faire huit dames
je pense façon il va arrêter le pion à
facilement
il va faire ses cinq avocats et des six
comme ça qui est b5 échec et c'est fini
maintenant à 4 h 5 prend quand même sont
en ue tu apprends à 3 ou qe3 est
normalement le 3 contre 0 là bas il fait
mal alors il ya aussi dit mme irène qui
a finalement battu sa reach et ghs
riccio que ça à faire du luxe et les
pandas qui vont prendre le lead au final
c'est pour vous dire à quel point ils
sont forts les les saint-louis les arcs
bishop
ce qui est un peu frustrant c'est que
plus tu progresses plus tu joues contre
des adversaires difficiles du coup ça
reste aussi difficile de gagner ouais
après car quand tu arrives à ton top 20
pays l'ont fait murray donc il ya quatre
et demi trois et demi quand arrive au
top des tops comme maxime en fait du
coup tu étais bien après tu sais que tu
bats cela il ya plus personne au dessus
mais je peux vous dire que ça joue très
très bien entre ils sont impressionnants
j'aimerais qu'ils vont devoir faire du
pied aux arméniens pour renforcer leur
équipe est complètement
un quatre et demi trois ennemis bon
écoute le match qui qui continuait reste
plus que 2 que deux manches
on a hâte russie pour les reprises des
candidats voient le 1er novembre
keller de la finale demain je crois que
c'est 19 heures quelqu'un a lu son
bouquin joueurs des chats car moi je les
dédicaces à la maison mais je n'ai pas
lu mais je les dédicacer ce qui fait
très plaisir je vous cache pas qu'à voir
le bouquin de maxime dédicaces et ça
fait plaisir
très très franchement j'ai un endroit
avec les bouquins dédicaces et j'ai les
mangas de kev lucky et loïc y sont
dédicacés j'en ai deux ou trois dédicacé
de je crois et j'ai le bouquin de maxime
dédicaces et j'ai j'ai peut-être baky
aussi qui m'a dédicacé un truc il faut
le dire ouais je sais je sais je sais ça
arrive que je conclure il est en vente
chez alpha bâ qui oui bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr alpha échec tous les bons
livres sont chez alfa échec chaque année
de vlad dédicaces et non
vinny de pnl daisy luxe à vendre toi
aussi tu allais qui y dédicacer sa fait
plaise l'avouer
ce que j'apprends ça
faire un livre d'échec ouais bah qui m'a
proposé en vrai mais c'est plus une
question de temps qu'autre chose faite
je fais déjà trop de choses et j'ai déjà
vraiment pas de temps en fait j'aurais
besoin de me clonés pour avoir une
deuxième version mois qu'ils fassent
qu'il fasse d'autres trucs mais c'est
vraiment une qualité qu'une question de
temps en fait ce n'est qu'une question
de temps
en fait si je faisais un livre aurait
repris les parties pédagogique et
j'aurais fait une compilation et les
battles j'aurais fait une compilation
des erreurs des amateurs un livre de
compilation des erreurs parce que ça
existe pas vraiment et ça aurait été une
autre approche pédagogique intéressante
donc j'aurais fait ça
à nantes
tu as joué contre 4 du rire jonah hill
est bon un cap du rire jaune ça
ressemble à une demi journée type
généralement je me lève à 8h30 je prends
mon petit déj
je bosse sur l'ordi je fais je fais tout
ce qui est vidéos youtube tout ce qui
est petit travail comme sa vidéo youtube
nanani nanana préparation tournage
réseaux sociaux et tout le matin on va
dire entre 9h 9h30 et 12h30 après je
mange
après je fais une sieste à j'essaie de
faire une sieste de 13h30 à 15h après je
me lève relève vers 15 heures je fais
quelques trucs que j'ai à faire
j'ai envie de dire de maintenance
générale pendant une heure une heure et
demie jusqu'à 16h 16h30 j'essaye de
refaire une sieste je me relève à 18
heures et après entre 18 heures
19h je commence à stream est en fête et
le stream jusqu'à minuit en général et à
répétition le lendemain matin
en gros mais journée ça ressemble un peu
à ça donc 9h30 12h30 je passe une
première fois après pause déjeuner
jusqu'à 13h30 je mange 15h jeu reprend 6
e
si j'ai du boulot des trucs à faire de
maintenant général entre 15 et 16 peut
être des réunions avec chaises comme ce
plat tout un petit truc comme ça je le
fais sinon si j'ai le temps si j'ai une
journée libre en fait je vais marcher
du coup je vais m'acheter un truc sucrés
dans une tartelette framboise je la
mange est quelque part donc je vais
faire un petit tour à pied d'une heure
ce hasard après je retourne du coup un
peu me reposer dormir et où m'allonger
tranquille mettre une série et à savoir
vers 16h30 et je remets le réveil vers
18h pour pour commencer à stream en fait
est-ce que c'est compatit avec le bout
de ma femme pas du tout non fait ma
femme elle elle par le matin genre 8h50
et elles rendent vers 18 heures au
moment où je commence à stream en fait
en général
taseer sur la quadrette tu peux tu peux
tu peux me croiser sur l'a3 est en train
de bouffer une tartelette framboise de
temps en temps vers vers 16h ouais c'est
possible est-ce qu'on me reconnaisse
dans la rue et ouais ça arrive c'est
rare mais ça arrive ça arrive mais ça ne
me dérange pas spécialement enfin tu as
et je suis même plutôt content quoi l on
me dit doit on aime bien ce que tu fais
bravo pour le boulot quoi et tu as ça me
fait plutôt plaisent mais du coup mes
journées sont très bien
j'ai découvert cannes ya trois semaines
un petit salon de thé pas loin de la
gare avec des cookies à 3 euros super
bon mais je vois de quoi tu parles
mais c'est pas mon spot à l'exerçons
c'est pas mon spot
tu m'aurais dit je dois donner les
meilleurs spots cameron photo proposant
une version de thé conduit comme dodge
en ligne twitter leur tige et c'est
ouais pas par contre si c'est à
quelqu'un qui me reconnaît dans la rue
qui me propose de jouer aux échecs ça me
saoule un peu tu vois c'est un peu comme
je sais pas quel est votre boulot mais
si je te propose de travailler tu vois
c'est à quelqu'un qui me croisent dans
la rue qui me dire bonjour que faire un
set suivant un autographe ça je fais ça
arrive
si c'est pour discuter de choses et
d'autres et touche toujours super
content par contre si c'est pour me re
parler d'échec
ça me saoule assez vite tu vois pas
comme chez dc ma pause elles et entre 15
et 16 là je suis en train de me faire ma
petite pause tranquille et où la
dernière chose dont j'ai vraiment envie
de parler c'est d'échec et surtout jouer
une partie d'échecs tu vois pas ce que
j'ai déjà fait j'ai déjà fait le matin
youtube des trucs des machins
je vais refaire 6h de stream le soir tu
vois j'ai déjà hâte à 9h30 des chèques à
9h d'échec dans la soirée si en plus
donc je fais des poses on leur parle
d'échec
ça va bien se passer un le meilleur spot
c'est l'asiad favori du la dre bien sûr
ça c'est le spot à connaître c'est le
spot en fait
un café championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur route à la place webb a
exactement alors tiges et c'est à ben
alaoui là si demain tu me croiser demain
dans la rue et que tu me demande ce que
je pense du championnat du monde de
cyclisme sur route qui va ce qui va se
courir demain après voilà je suis très
heureux quoi là je suis très heureux
parce que je pense que vous devez en art
est favori mais bon après avoir à huy
est là là là là c'est des discussions si
tu me parles si tu me parles toulouse
exeter qui est en train de se joue en ce
moment là je suis heureux à là on va
parler un moment d'entrer surprenant la
victoire du racing mais lallaoui là la
discussion peut durer ah là là ça peut
s'éterniser et même si ça commence par
les deux sujets très intéressants comme
celui là ah oui complètement
on va parler de jirau on va parler on va
on va se faire plaisir là sûr que si tu
me parles de la berlinoise
bon je vais je vais essayer de me barrer
rapidos mais avec un jam qui vas-tu de
temps que tu vas faire des échecs au tir
mais en fait moi je considère pas
vraiment que je fais des échecs à
proprement parler pour lui sans battre
mais sinon en vrai pas beaucoup le
racing est contre les saracens way truc
de ouf truc complètement inattendu
on peut parler roland garros météo est
ce que la pluie va favoriser nadal ou
pas moi je pense pas je peux
brice brice h malheureusement toulouse
exactair même si j'ai le téléphone en
dessous quand même pour cech
parce que quand même on va être on va
être quand même très très sérieux bon là
c'est la mi-temps mais on va être très
sérieux j'ai quand même mis le truc pour
voir avec le score de temps en temps
j'ai trouvé le racing de plutôt bien
arbitré
la ligue 1 an oui à 14 ans pour les
anglais ça j'ai vu
mais après
accueil des grands maîtres et touche par
il ya déjà un peu les masters passer ce
genre de choses et les moments il passe
95 cents trente après après malgré tout
ma chaîne ça reste une chaîne perso tu
vois quoi qu'il en soit donc
les faq
c'est serait ce ce serait plus plus à
propos ci faisait sur leur chaîne ou sur
leurs réseaux en fait avec maxime on
avait fait un peu une faq interview tu
vois ça arrive de le faire mais à une
faq à proprement dire du coup c'est pas
vraiment bref quand il commente il
répond aux questions du chat web
mais chacun
elle va fabi le fait souvent eh ouais
tous les intervenants qui passe gaby gab
sont rémunérés sauf sauf maxime je
dirais et baky mais qui parce qu'ils
passent comme ça en guest on va dire qui
prend voilà finalement à l arménie
impressionnante leur tige et c'est alors
après ce qui va avoir une baisse de
régime je disais ils peuvent à tout
moment avoir une baisse de régime mais
messi continue sur le niveau qu'ils ont
produit jusqu'ici devrait l'emporter
assez facilement contre contre l'équipe
de saint louis après on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'une baisse de régime
j'ai pas vu manchester dans les clubs
piano à siffler après la fin du matche
peter et ils vont aligner la même équipe
que contre les tchèques bras ouais ouais
ouais bah je peux remontrer 1 les
équipes demain parce que je pensais
quand même un sujet intéressant le match
pour la troisième place a pas vraiment
d'enjeu si voulez parler un peu du match
de demain voilà le saint louis qui aura
caruana dominguez son exil on garde ça
c'est la même équipe mais bon en face il
ya max ou de loups qui va gros joueurs
quand même
qui a été champion du monde juniors est
presque 2007 yalla yalla yalla doublette
arménienne martirossian petrossian aux 2
et 3 qui vont faire mal et le petit ça
douanières qui a fait des étincelles
ils me paraissent très dangereux après
comme je disais ils sont affaiblis par
l'absence de sarkissian et martirossian
qui ont qui avaient des pères faute
suite 2820 je croise actions qui leur de
28 62 perf qui absent à la surprise
générale pour ces finales et andré
ancian qu'on voit plus trop non plus sur
les people etc
donc ils auront ils ont ces deux joueurs
qui sont un petit peu absente et des
joutes sur internet ces dernières
semaines et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
un affaiblissement clair pour pour les
arméniens mais je suis quand même assez
confiant
voilà les équipes pour demain avec pour
moi quand même sur les arméniens
peut-être légèrement favori après après
on attend une surprise de l'équipe de
saint louis 1 qui peut arriver comme je
vous dis c'est jamais une baisse de
régime des arméniens pourraient leur
coûter cher
double attaque e5
ouais alors 5 c'était jouable mais c'est
une double attaque toute relative
puisque puisque surface
déjà je peux prendre mais si je veux
juste travailler que tu prends je
reprends c'est un échange avec version
attend en attend une surprise ou ads de
saint louis mais réellement je pense
vraiment que les arméniens sont favoris
je ne croyais pas
on verra on verra intéressant la
position là les tchèques drague son pied
du mur
c'est le cas de le dire
ça se passe quand le métier de streamer
s'est pas inscrite à lui monté sa propre
société en gros tu râles as tout le
temps quid isle of et des cinq ça
ouvrirait trop la position à l'ébranler
brasles au fond des chaussettes à elle
serait dur pour eux de perdre les deux
matches là au pied de la muraille bien
joué le chou s'améliore ça améliore
inglee à rennes contre contre hugo
lloris a sûrement faire annuler cette
histoire pareille contre eux oui c'est
énorme des changes la française écrite
chose qui serait pas contre une nouvelle
nul parce que je suis déjà appréhendé
partir d'un enterrement qui aurait pas
assez bien qu'ouvert à n'ont jamais à
double vrai
après vu quant aux relations d'audience
potentiel et de relations de l'audience
potentielle par rapport à la langue vu
que quand je couvre des événements je
toujours numéro un de tous les streamer
qu'ils ont c'est difficile de
représenter quelqu'un qui fait numéro 1
tout le temps tu vois pour les candidats
à la phase retour sera dans le même
ordre que la face
ouais que la phase aller weatherill
asticots elle sera dans le même ordre et
salue françois jack
du coup je me fais je me fais pas
anglais tous les événements c'est
toujours bien couvert
est-ce que j'ai commencé un travail
presque sommes prêts à relancer ma
chaîne
j'ai commencé à bosser pour 3com cinq
ans après avoir lancé ma chaîne ça
finira sur une nouvelle née powe qui
pourrait valoir de l'or
mais après
après pas dire les candidats c'est long
on verra quand ça reprend va pas faire
il ya six rondes 1 qui qui sépare ce
duel on va pas faire de plan sur la
comète
non en vrai en relation audience et
potentiel d'audience je crois que je
suis deuxième derrière hikaru hikaru qui
m'a dépassé avec avec l'époque james
hikaru qui m'a dépassa va avec avec tous
les pucks scheme aps le buzz qu'ils ont
avec x qc tout ça icaro a fait l'écart
après je m'en fous un peu je vais te
dire mais du coup il car ou hikaru qui
m'a un peu mis dans le rétro elle je
dois je dois je dois reconnaître excusé
c'est le plus gros streamer monde
c'est l'esprit m'a fait le plus
d'audience au monde du coup comme icare
ou a beaucoup stream et avec lui sa sas
a bien fait décoller sa chaîne c'est un
peu comme si du jour au lendemain j'ai
commencé à faire des vidéos avec squeeze
quoi et pendant un mois un mois et demi
à 11 et à une dizaine de vidéos ensemble
ça ferait ça ferait décoller la chaîne
de ouf
cancel bah en fait tu sais combien de
gens qui regardent chaque langage abdul
le vrai don des langues différentes et
juste pour exemple en fait ma chaîne
perso c'est la deuxième chaîne des
chèques à être entré dans le top 100 des
chaînes regardées dans un pays sûr
twitch la première c'était hikaru du
coup et a du coup la mienne c'était la
deuxième fois il y en a que deux pour le
moment il ya juste la mienne et celle du
caroux même si fait ressortir et re
rentrer peut-être plus tard comme chez
beaucoup de déveine pansement sur czech
comme france mais en gros on est les
deux seules à avoir réussi à faire ça ce
qui est pas mal ce qui est pas mal
donc non il m'engueule patois j'essaye
toujours de bien couvrir au maximum 1
après c'est vrai que là pour des matchs
de troisième place de process liquide
est pas vraiment disons que le contenu
être pas vraiment à faire des
commentaires de feu parce que il n'y a
pas d'enjeu on sent les joueurs qui sont
un peu en demi-teinte
même les stream des bras et des équipes
concernées il ya personne qui regarde
donc à ccc passe et passe pas évident
quoi on regarde un peu les parties comme
ça un peu à l'arraché mais on va dire
que c'est pas évident
c'est pas évident
est ce que tu sais si mbia un coach
mental ça non
sa non ça je sais pas
tant souri aux américains c'est pareil
tout est ce qui compte ah non non mais
c'est vrai que c'est match pour la
troisième place c'est toujours un peu un
peu spéciale entre guillemets à l'équipe
de chips ça rigole pareil mais bon sont
fait éliminés hier 1,85 ding il est bien
d'ailleurs
mais c'est vrai que seeding gagner va
faire l'écart
nomao a pris un coach mental et coach
mental et à prendre un coach mental de
temps en temps de manière ponctuelle
entre les tournois et à prendre un coach
mental à plein temps est-ce qu' une
raison pour le que le diminutif
d'alexander soit sacha alors je connais
pas la raison je sais que c'est
diminutif mais je sais pas pourquoi
alexander ça deviens sacha faire et que
je demande
les gagnants vraiment perdu contraire
bien oui oui bah oui enfin la logique a
été respectée en tout la logique a été
respectée
donc là il vous la finale pour la petite
finale pour la troisième place
mais
rien aucune chance contre saint louis
moi je les mets favoris en tout mais
après chacun ses pronos un chacun ses
pronos
c'est assez solide quand même pour les
blancs même s'ils commencent petit à
petit à pouvoir être moins bienveillants
guy yakich les arméniens il ya max ou de
l'uia martirossian il ya petrossian il
ya le petit ça doit ni c'est une grosse
équipe
c'est ça ouais ça peut ça peut ça peut
être très serré bien sûr ouais ouais sur
internet tant qu'ils ont joué sur
internet comme je disais je crois qu'ils
ont je crois qu'ils ont qu'une défaite
en fait donc c'est une équipe qui perd
quasiment jamais quant à une équipe qui
perd pas ici quasiment jamais moi je la
mets favorite 1
favorite après chacun sa vision du
pronostic
chacun sa vision du pronostic bon
regling est vraiment mieux sacha ça a
fait un nul ici c'est tendu et ici c'est
tendu
le match peut être serrée après demain
on verra ce que ça donne
reprenant b6 et yappa tourbe et 4 passes
4.7 et fous ces cinq gars qui dans
l'équipe de saint louis
caruana sow domingues et geffré zhang
après je peux me tromper un mois les
arméniens jérémy minimum demi finale
cette année et en sachant que que ça
joue pas en norvège mais que ça se joue
à domicile je les ai mis gagnant mais
après je peux me tromper un après je
peux me tromper et tour ses six tours
ces six fours e3 peut-être qu'avec
lycées 6 a fait retour à 8 fouet 3 il va
essayer d'envoyer les deux pions passé
c'est pas sûr qu'il la gagne c'est en
réel on tourne on sait ils ont ils
devaient jouer en norvège normalement
mais ça joue à domicile va cause de duke
au vide
à cause du comice à devait jouer en
norvège en fait ces demi-finales et
cette finale
et puis du coup ça ça a été annulé près
comme chilien je peux me tromper un jeu
pas la science infuse mais messi avant
prenons à faire ce serait ce serait
celui-là
si j'avais un prono ce serait celui-là
tahari mons à jour ici ou là la qualité
de plus et tout ça a gagné pour sa reach
il va choper l'union prend b2 quand même
la finale c'est demain 19h je crois je
crois que c'est demain à 19 heures
iran la calloc'h sa reach mais il va
tout raser
c'est hyper chaud lors bikidik ces
gagnants après fou des quatre pour wii
puisque tu attaques laet attaque là à
oui non ça fait très mal et tu veux pas
prendre ce cas cavaliers yakari
l'épreuve trois échecs
donc ça c'est gagner ça d'inghem qui
réfléchisse parce que c'est hyper
compliqué qui aimait opposition entre
banquiers mazet bas qui abat qui a été
top 10 mondial quand même hein mais même
si maso et très fort positionnement on
peut pas comparer quoi top 10 mondial
c'est énorme et gars donc ça va faire un
un ok ça va faire petit lait normalement
les chinois seront devant bas qui est un
monstre à
mais ça avance 30 rue de stream entre
carey il se débrouille pas mal il se
débrouille pas mal
donc
ça ça doit gagner mais c'est pas fait
encore ça ça va gagner pour les chinois
ça ça doit gagner pour les chinois et ça
ça doit faire un nul on connaît les
chinois qui pourrait encore faire un
point d'écart
il pourrait faire deux et demi 1/2 un
ennemi pardon
après baky c'est aussi un monstre en
stream 1
voilà le truc skybet malleray roye b 5 à
4 à 5 à 6 et en fait on va contrôler
toutes les cases ça va gagner sa
terrible peut être le pion à f4 et
poussé le pion
ces affaires f4 juste parce qu'à finale
de pions elle gagne s'il prend et après
il a envoyé le pion m c'était sûr qu'il
aurait comme ça donc digne qui va mettre
le point
l'aca reach il est peut-être moins
gayant tout à l'heure même si ça doit
être gagnant oui si c'est une question
de calcul mais dans un faux problème de
cavaliers ou quatre qui fait mal a écrit
chucky la plante inquiets français 5
l'autre a pas vu une enfilade
ah oui c'est terrible à tours 1 c'est
terrible comme gaffe quand même terrible
ouais ça c'est une énorme gaffe 1 3
terrible gaffe donc ça pourrait faire
2-2 et garder le suspens entre
guillemets layada me prend hd aussi
qu'un candidat d'ailleurs éric en sus à
s'endetter pour finir quatrième fois non
les gars ils ont ils ont dix mille saab
ils ont des contrats tubes et tous ne
t'inquiète pas pour t'inquiète pas pour
eux ne t'inquiète pas pour eux un netto
reprend f7 alors ils pensaient à il
pensait avoir tout rui tempête mais il
était en échec
il a cru que c'était ma toile alors sa
riche qui a pas réussi à gagner il s'est
fait il s'est fait tenir par li chao wii
qui a gagné du coup guy qui va perdre et
gris tout qui va gagner donc ça va faire
ça à faire 7 5
c'est terrible il a cru qu'il allait
faire maths
voilà c'est fini j'ai six g7-g8 dirait
qu'il va encore perdre dirais qu'il ya
combien il va reste un an et demi sur
trois guéri qui fait pas une grande
phase finale rich ou quand même qui sort
le jeu sigrid shukla gagne pas celle là
déjà si la gagne son mal mais si gris
choo gagne pas celle-là c'est quasi
finie
il peut quasi ils peuvent case quasi
rentrer chez eux à pied
c'est terrible ouais les pieds à
mais bon c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
compliqué de mettre beaucoup d'argent
dans cette compétition 1
parce que même si fait une équipe
compétitive soit on a déjà les arméniens
et saint louis qui sont vraiment très
très fort les deux donc tu es
complètement bloquée mais même avec une
équipe tata aussi l'équipe de chine quoi
tu as quand même trois énormes équipe et
c'est dur de lutter c'est vraiment très
difficile de lutter la spa il veut jouer
cavalier ou cinq prises à vii
du coup à faire piéger ou kg 5 ouais bon
le roi va monter mais c'est vrai qu'il
réussit pas arriver jusqu'ici
même les chinois tu suivrait pas les
arméniens tu suis vraiment de ouf
moment il a raté ce qui peut pas faire
tout rejet de tout rejet troyat le pion
qui part donc il l'a raté ouais donc là
l'écart va être trop trop important le
match est plié là c'est sûr bon là c'est
là c'est nul de chez nul mais bon les
chinois y va alors monté un point pour
gagner les a rien entre budget c'est
juste une bande de potes les arméniens
très bien entrés très bien organisée
très forts qui ont fait un peu la razzia
pendant longtemps sur les title tuesday
qu'il a et qui la font la razzia très
entraînés sur internet quoi vraiment
spécial ici doivent se faire du sparring
partner à fond et tout pour pour
vraiment être très fort sur internet se
sont vraiment bien spécialisés c'est
vrai qu'il faut un peu là ils ont peu
fait la razzia pendant des années sur
sur sur pas mal de tournois sur le net
très fort pas donc là cet ennemi quatre
et demi mais les bras a les bras qui n'y
sont plus les bras qui vont perdre
d'hommes
je pas de chance pour les bras
ses charmes pour eux
ses charmes pour eux mêmes mais là ils
ont ils sont ils sont ils sont foutus
écoutez c'est comme ça
arrive
les braqueurs une bonne grosse équipe
mais bon là les chinois ils sont
vraiment forts aussi un bon c'est
terrible tu prends les arméniens grand
favori de la compet en demi et derrière
même le match pour la troisième place en
fait fait le match en plus ils te coûte
un bras à jouer ce match pour la
troisième place fait vu le prix en jeu
le vainqueur gagne 4000 de plus mais en
fait tu préfères juste ne pas jouer le
match en fait je pense côté bras
financièrement parlant
c'est bauer s'en fait de ne pas jouer
parce que c'est pas vrai nom l'équipe
ait beaucoup de passes a en tout mais
non ça c'est plus intéressant de faire
forfait en fait
ici le monde ks raymond kalla et surtout
que t'as pas de spectateurs que tout le
monde s'en fout quoi côté bras donc tu
mets rahman en train de baisser ya
autant de gens qui regardent quoi après
peut-être des gens qui font des sables
ift
mais bon c'est l'écrasent adha
tupperware tu paies les joueurs par
match généralement double est ce pas là
700 dure autant faire déjà en gambie
thème un milliard pour les 2000 ont fait
un pic à 899 joueur tu vois pas mon cas
w f1 sait rien en fait
ça te coûte un bras pour rien en fait
mon kaiser mon k w mon cas mon cas tout
un tas ils sont marchés dessus
on est 344 ou alors qu'on en a pas grand
chose à faire en soit ces matches trois
troisièmes places et où ils sont c'est
leur équipe y met
ils ont ils ont défoncé leur
porte-monnaie ils sont ils ont ils ont
700 personnes comme un fou quelles
ambitions aux franchisés question qu'on
connaît pas les équipes feraient jesse
may hamm et mais bon comme je disais
juste avant il ya de tels épouvantail
imagine tu décides de mettre de l'argent
imagine tu décides de m on va dire
quinze mille euros pour faire une équipe
on se bat on met des saab on dit allez
on fait un objectif à 4000 sablon soit
une équipe de ouf
ok on joue les armées ni en quarts de
finale on est quasi éliminé on peut on
peut pas on pourra pas rivaliser
c'est qu'ils beaucoup trop forte pour
nous donc
à un moment donné ça sert à quoi en fait
c'est yahia pas d'explication pour
expliquer qu'on va être une telle somme
pour de toute façon que nos chances
soient très réduite de remporter la
compétition
c'est compliqué et puis bon mizan t'as
déjà ça puis même si tous me contre
saint loup quoi c'est déjà des équipes
très fortes ou les bras ou les chinois
comme tu le vois ou quoi
on va quand même pas mal d'équipés
pouvant taille et puis tu as une équipe
vraiment plus forte que les autres
donc c'est un peu un peu compliqué ouais
après après s'il ya un mécène un gars
qui dit les gars on se fait l'équipe 10
blitz crime je vous envoie 15000 euros
et vous faites une équipe pourquoi pas
pour parce que le gars ça le fait kiffer
qui veut que et qui veut qu'on fasse
l'équipe la wii mais pour moi en fait ça
a pas de
il n'y a pas d'explication si tu veut
rationnelle pour que pour que je dépense
beaucoup d'argent pour faire une équipe
en fait d'ailleurs maxime qui jouent
gratuitement et c'est tous les joueurs
jouent gratuitement et tout pour
s'amuser quoi après après ça ce serait
sympa de faire une équipe mais bon tu
mettrais qui l'entouré dit que ça budget
illimité ben mvl gris tchouk déjà ça
c'est sûr les bonnes tu penses mveng
riccio cleven et et magnus je vois
qu'ils n'ont pas d'équipé quoi pas gris
tout du coup on le ferait signer mais
comme c'est un pote ça on n'y arriverait
les bonnes il a pas de clubs aimeraient
jouer avec nous et magnus il a pas de
club vous viviez limiter ça pourrait
faire une petite équipe sympa mais bon
ça ne fait peut-être pas une équipe qui
gagne quand même c'est terrible
comment tu penses que darien ont réussi
à être plus forte en aide quand c'était
en lan l'année où ils ont gagné
bah ils ont été été bien quand ils sont
arrivés en demi finale il y avait une
limite à deux mille cinq cents lots pas
mme sow et gia et du coup ils ont ils
ont surpris ils ont surpris tout le
monde
après c'était des matches très très
serré mais il ya veille avait cette
limite et lokua qui faisait que toutes
les équipes avaient à peu près le même
niveau et après la deuxième fois où ça a
été en lan
les demi finales ils sont fait écraser
en demi on est en match pour la
troisième place
ils n'ont pas vraiment existé mais met
donc en fait en lan ils ont deux sur
quatre dans leurs matchs avec les
limites à 2005 et sur internet ils
doivent avoir fait plus et tu sais plus
quel est le nom mais peut-être 35
victoires une défaite ou quelque chose
comme ça
elles sont les prix les prix sont assez
petits puisque le vainqueur gagne 20
mille dollars frais chess à la limite et
l'ol elle favorise un peu les chinois
mais qui essaie pas spécialement d'en
tirer profit
avec radars qui sont partis en
armageddon contre les pandas sans
limitation ouais je crois que la
première finale de pro chelsea qu'il
avait gagné en armageddon et c'est ça
c'était c'était très serré la première
finale
après je voudrais bien il joue très bien
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
mais non là les chinois les chinois les
chinois qui ont vraiment une grosse
équipe enfin ils sont vraiment très
forts
mais les arts vient et je crois qu'ils
ont toujours fait demi-finale en fait
y'a pas une saison ils sont fait
éliminées avant l'ère van ly lan sont
toujours aller en demies en fait de
mémoire combien de temps maggie choix
2016 non son premier titre sa prise du
titre ou déjà avant tiens tu roules à de
mémoire alors on s'attend s'attend qu'à
une victoire des pandas il faut qu'il
marque un point sur trois et c'est fini
donc soit 2 nuls soit une victoire sur
quatre parties 2013 à 2016 c'est déjà la
défense du titre ' vois tu vois je fais
tellement longtemps qui est championne
du monde que je raconte n'importe quoi
mais non c'était plus longtemps qu'en
2007 2016 c'est vrai que quatre en ruine
en 2013 oui ça paraît plus cohérent fait
tellement longtemps qu'ils champion du
monde maintenant c'est fou pas 2016
c'est déjà un match de défense du titre
est
il peut rester encore combien de temps à
mon avis longtemps à mon avis au moins
six ans à mon avis au moins six ans
parce que dans cette génération de
joueurs c'est de loin le plus fort et
après faudrait à mon avis l'émergence
d'un joueur comme fil rouge à pour le
détrôner à moins qu'ils perdent un match
voilà contre caruana et contre carrer
qui nous a pu les perdre
mais il est quand même le plus fort
joueurs de cette génération et je vois
pas un jour de cette génération est
dépassé après sur un match tout est
possible
c'est comme si moi je défends ce que
j'aimerais vrai je pense celui où il ya
eu le meilleur niveau c'était celui
contre caruana le dernier c'était très
chaud pour faire l'équipe dont je
parlais à la fois ça reviendra à combien
bah on va dire compte 1000 $ par joueur
et par match
je sais pas je donne le chiffre moyen je
suis pas s'ils demandent un peu plus ou
un peu moins on va dire on va dire qu'on
négocie race à tuffé x 4 x 8
donc ça fait trente deux mille plus les
phases finales 40000 sans compter magnus
way
et des passeurs de gagner et était même
pas sûr de gagner que cette équipe mais
les prix tu gagnes tu gagnes tu gagnes
20000 et je suis même pas sûr que tu le
fasses mais on va dire si tu leur
propose de jouer tous les matches ça
fait ça fait 10 10 10 dix jours de jeudi
mille c'est sur internet n'y a pas
d'enjeu ça joue pas pour le classement
tu as une chance d'y arriver mais je
suis même pas sûr que tu arrives un méta
une chance d'y arriver
ces chars étaient loin d'être sûr de
gagner parce que si tu joues contre
saint louis par m là tu comptes les
chinois ding la reine yu yang wei li
chao s'était jamais sûr de gagner en
fait contre cette équipe n'importe ictu
met d'ailleurs
et ils sont même pas en finale les
américains tuent mais sow caruana machin
et tout est pas sûr de gagner un même
avec mvele 40 scènes et compagnie si tu
enlèves card sen t encore moins sur
entre guillemets
tu étais vraiment est vraiment pas
garantie d'une victoire quoi
tu es vraiment pas garantie d'une
victoire
tu prends de cire ou jamais mais bon fil
rouge hafsi rhodia est quand même bien
moins fort que mv al aronian karl scène
et griche aucun
si je prends un haka carlson mvl saut je
pense que tu es déjà encore voilà la
latte est quand même très très bien mais
bon là tu es plus qu'à 4000 par match
batta beaucoup plus que quatre minutes
par match la talent à la talata plus de
portefeuille là mais oui avec cette
équipe là tu vas gagner et ce sera même
pas marrant en fait tu va écraser tout
le monde
là tu vas même pas t'amuser je pense
même l'arménie tueur mais 14,2 je pense
même l'arménie la leur alors leur niveau
de jeu suivi par là
là c'est fini on attend le début des
dernières parties de ce match pour la
troisième place
mais franchit les fournitures roule sur
la proue chess ligue très fort foehn ce
californien alain
c'est un moment qu'on a pas vu
on s'impatiente un peu du début de cette
dernière ronde
c'est un patienter un petit peu
[Musique]
une grande pause une grande et longue
pause
feyer l'essai qui fait malgré l'essai du
28 à 28 à 10 c'est terrible
sylvain brive où mark et moi il faut
trois points et demi pour revenir est
exactement
il faut mettre trois points et demi pour
revenir
avant on attend que ça reprenne en fait
je pensais que ça reprendra 18h
honnêtement
on attend j'attends comme vous ils ont
dû vouloir faire une pause plus longue
pour bien pour bien équiper le la
dernière à la dernière ronde de ce match
pour la troisième place et j'ai pas
encore eu le temps d'essayer tft non tu
vois je suis un peu bloqué avec tous ces
stream là j'ai pas mal de compet chasse
comme le speech est junior
et salue monsieur à
tu pas qu'on sert à repartir
qu'est ce que je sais c max à fait
réussi à faire top old guys vu qu'on le
sait pas c'est qu'il n'a pas faibli
stendhal ce t'inquiète pas que si la
leaf étape 1 on serait au courant s'il
n'a pas eu tort si on n'est pas au
courant d'un copain de maxime sait qu'il
y en a pas eu allez c'est reparti avec
une anglaise
c'est reparti avec une anglaise
on va voir ce que ça donne jette un oeil
au chat heures
youtube est gentil parlait mais du coup
on n'aura pas répondu
donc cette petite anglaise ici thierry
fritsch ou que ça assez insipide ça
comme position et gambit dame dans
l'énigme zoo structure gambie table
c'est une petite italienne
et ça c'est une foule et cinq échecs
dans la sicilienne on va rester
allez sur great chou que ding
ça développe alors si main car ayant eu
quatre un jour ou l'autre
pour le moment c'est bien tenues comme
case va faire flouer fuite
qui se cache solis a peut-être faire des
plombs porno ou un pion isoler les
menaces qui agissent quel point f7 faut
faire gaffe
bon il faut qu'ils gagnent tous les bras
de façon ils n'ont pas de question à se
poser c'est davantage mais côté chinois
doit pouvoir faire des nuls
voilà fait g6 alors ça empêche le truc
dans le sens sur karachi ce faire roy g7
maintenant il perd pas et 7 et ouais la
finale de la champion's cup sera exonère
racing j'ai envie de dire bonne chance
bonne chanson racing 1 puisque exact
heures ça a pas l'air d'être des facile
à manoeuvrer un limon l'air d'être assez
fort ça m'a l'air d'être assez rapides
derrière faudra un grand racing pour
pour venir à bout des visiteurs cette
année
je suis un peu déçu pour toulouse quand
même mais bon c'est comme ça
mission ariane tahri d'accord c'est la
petite italienne le fou 3 cette
position-là déjà 800 encore théorique
c'est sûr ici c'est double fiant kétou
fatigue toujours
dufour b4 ici
pour le 4 et à s'en prendre au cheval
tête des cinq aussi patiné sur du mal à
jouer ses positions là
c'est fou bekkat icloud cavaliers
façon rien à voir à 3 faut prendre ces
trois dames ces deux ci a prononcé trois
et faire quatre possibles des cinq mois
je pense que c'est rose rawson vers alex
person qui a monté le montrer le staff
or gambie le gambit stafford standford
queen's appel à elles veulent échanger
poussé au centre est il a échangé pour
gagner le contrôle de ces deux cases
cette position là on a vu plein
notamment une partie je pensais nouvelle
mamediarov vous mamediarov envel où ça
se tient avec les noirs ça peut être un
peu chiant mais ça siens ça c'est avec
les noix qu'est la série
une position intéressante pour essayer
de gagner avec les noirs justement ici
gris tube doit gagner avec les blancs
bon
on va laisser le match se déroulait un
c'est pas évident de suivre catéchistes
ya à la fois belle et c'est le truc se
jouer on verra bien si les chinois
réussissent à mettre à point
or à bien
on verra bien on verra bien si c'est un
clip en l'apprenant les positions sont
toutes assez égal dans les chinois ils
savent bien faire nul en plus les six
n'ont besoin que d'un point pour gagner
le match fut un demi point pour
s'assurer déjà les départage du coup ça
veut dire qu'ils savent qu'une nul c'est
bien quoi quand tu as besoin d'un point
déjà tu peux être hésitant à tout jouer
pour la nulle en disant si ça craque de
partout si on joue trop pour faire nul
on peut carrément perdre là quand tu
sais que la moindre nul tu as sur le
match
les départage ça facilite vraiment les
choses iraient aussi ouais c'est bien
faire nul il ya déjà eu une nulle entre
guy et à aiguillon guy alors ça c'est
étonnant franchement guérissent et ce
serait mon coéquipier au chant et
capitaine de l'équipe c'est du foutage
de gueule en fait honnêtement il a les
blancs il fait nul là dans une situation
où on doit tous gagnés franchement je le
vire de l'équipe pour la saison
prochaine un truc pareil
c'est juste un correct tu tu dois jouer
en fait va faire nul en vain coup ici
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible en
fait
bon ben ça veut dire que les pandas a
plus besoin que d'une nulle sur les
trois échiquier où ils ont deux fois les
blancs non mais là c'est eric defert nul
avec les blancs pas après peut-être
qu'il est déjà moins bien mais je sais
pas en fait tu dois te punir et jouer et
perdre en fait je passe chez dams et
quatre tours des huit tours d'un et tu
dois totaux punir je sais pas comment tu
joues mais tu dois totaux punir c'est ok
tu vas perdre et qui va être une merde
ou quoi mais tu dois totaux punir est
allé la perdre c'est tout tu peux pas
faire nul dans une telle situation
surtout grille tout cas peut-être une
bonne position ici fait le taff et du
coup après tu as trois joueurs tu mets
la pression parce que là tu mets aucune
pression en fait il en a absolument rien
à faire mais c'est ce que je vous disais
les joueurs à mon avis ans il s'en cogne
un peu les supporters de l'équipe des
bras s'en cogne aussi absents que c'est
vraiment un match superflu à titre perso
qui a pas forcément lieu d'être les
joueurs sont pas engagés vous sentez
mais moi je suis pas vraiment engagée
mais parce qu'on le ressent un que les
joueurs sont pas engagés dans le match
donc c'est dur d'être engagée quand tu
commentes ou quand tu suis quand tu sens
que les joueurs eux mêmes il ya personne
qui est vraiment impliqué là dedans le
dans ce match pour la troisième place
[ __ ] qui a perdu fait voir ça baky qui a
perdu jeter un oeil ça ça m'intéresse
quand même
spanish league
les parties terminées baky qui a perdu
contre chez paris 9 jette un oeil
staind qu'était une anti meyran ouest va
rentrer chiante elle quand elle a perdu
vite un fait une faute tactique ouais
ouais c'est terrible c'est terrible
pourquoi ce désintérêt bras parce que
c'est le match pour la troisième place
tom wright donc je pense que les joueurs
y lui jouer pour gagner la compétition
c'est déjà c'est une compétition amicale
donc ok il joue pour gagner la compet
mais tu vois il faut quand même assez
tranquille est ok une fois que tu t'es
fait éliminé battu theft éliminé quoi
y'a rien en jeu en fait déjà le titre
est quand même strictement honorifique
de base mais bon ok c'est un peu sympa
mais là ok une troisième place
honorifique je pense que personne je
pense que personne n'a vraiment quelque
chose à faire en fait
et c'est assez normal
c'est assez normal
pire il est huitième on galope n'est pas
sa place actuelle mais oui les dents
dans le top mondial oui
montrer mon plus qu'une nul aux chinois
pour aller en finale mois quand le match
sera plié je vous laisserai à une fois
que le score sera fait mais à mon avis
ça devrait arriver sur cet échiquier
avec un voire deux tours prend des cinq
prises des 5 prises sept
il va arriver incessamment sous peu
amaigri qui fait pas que des nuls un
geek un très bon joueur mais bon là en
plus il est pas très impliqué mais du
coup ça avec 7 nuls avec les blancs elle
laisse un peu un goût amer pour les
supporters des bras j'espère que demain
on aura un beau match j'espère des
arméniens en forme
le carré des cinq
mais salue au nom du fr sajoo et là ça
va échanger et changer la finale s'armer
ni contre saint louis on ne lui wade a
fait oublier les cowboys mais savent que
l'écho à l'écho il aurait pu être
champion du monde
ça joue à une partie son match contre
kramnik
on va voir
ça se passe aussi bien pour les chinois
qui a que great food qui met une grosse
pression sur ding le rsa pour la chine
il va y avoir un tight note
on va voir
ok tour des 7 e art ou re 4 et c'est
fini ton âge - 21 non non non non ça
reprend la semaine prochaine avec les
quarts de finale et encore sept matches
entre aby rim il a marqué deux points
pour sa team one on me l'a pas fait un
mauvais match c'est hier qu'il a fait un
très mauvais match aujourd'hui c'est
sarychev et tahri qui en plus de mal
le panda le l'emblème des pandas qui est
qui et hop je suis d'accord avec toi
autour des quatre dames 6 il va refaire
tour quatre genres faire bande des six
il joue pour sauver son équipe et 5h
demain je crois que ça à 19 heures gare
mais à vérifier puisque les horaires
changent souvent donc à vérifier sur
twitter par une taille normale on est
obligé de la jouer pour gagner
t'as pas le choix même si tu la perds si
tu répètes le match est terminé
immédiatement donc au moins c'est simple
tu es obligé de l'attenté à la tour des
quatre îles objet de refaire dames 6
tours 4 ça fait nul marrant quand même
c'est jazz vrac sont quand même pas
qu'on bâtit fin c'est marrant de donner
le match comme ça va je comprends pas en
fait tout re cat ok tu fais dam des six
tours 8 3 h 7 h 4 et puis mon madame des
3 es tu joues dame prend des trois toi
prends des 3es va te faire f 5 qui a
valu à je suis très malin mais je sais
pas on sait jamais tu vas sûrement la
perdre mais en fait si tu fais nul tu
donnes le match je ne comprends pas en
fait
en fait en faisant ça tu donnes le match
papa ne soit obligé de jouer à la ok
t'as fait nul est ok bravo et alors je
trouve c'est des décisions bizarres
quand même de faire deux nuls comme ça
être donné le match perso je comprends
pas trop la décision mais en tout cas
les bras qui qui donne qui donne le
match en fait littéralement
je peux pas comprendre ces décisions de
toute façon c'est un match éliminatoire
en faisant nul là tu condamnes ton
équipe immédiatement
j'allais voir un peu c'est pas la soupe
à la grimace du côté du stream des bras
mais mais c'est pour moi c'est terrible
de faire ça ouais c'est la soupe heures
gens sont quand même très contents ils
attendent la saison prochaine ouais je
sais pas
cze bat je trouve la décision vraiment
étrange l'apercevoir mais bon après de
façon il était perdant c'est vrai mais
ah ouais soupe à la grimace
ouais bon qui perd des deux derniers
matchs ils finiront trois quatrièmes de
la compet du coup médaille en chocolat
grosse équipe mais mais finalement pas
de médaille donc je remette une petite
pub
et puis nous on se retrouvera on se
retrouvera on se retrouvera demain quoi
pour la finale qui sera sympa pour la
peine pour la finale qui sera acquis
sera sympa donc on suivra ça on suivra
ça demain merci d'avoir su entre en ma
compagnie c'est ce match pour la
troisième place qui aura qu il y aura
pas eu trop de suspense finalement et
puis on se retrouve demain mon week-end
les gars merci
ciao ciao